notre quatrième sujet ce soir comme il
nous reste quelques minutes et qu'il est
savoureux voici un chercheur qui avoue
n'avoir jamais rien démontré il ne
procédait que par anecdote pour
conforter un point de vue idéologique de
base ne s'appuyant que sur des hauteurs
procédant de la même manière que lui et
en vingt ans il n'a jamais été
contredits il faut lire la longue est
stupéfiant de confessions de christopher
du mythe qui s'alarment aujourd'hui des
conséquences de son travail
il décrit le règne de l'autre soit et de
l'idéologie à l'université il est
canadien
oui mais en france aussi la conférence
de sylviane agacinski tout récemment a
été annulé après des menaces assez
violent des organisations comme riposte
trans ou bien les étudiants lgbt de
bordeaux alors l'université est elle
devenue sectaire je vais quand même vous
lire un petit bout de la confession de
notre repenti il écrit aujourd'hui
j'aimerais faire mon mea culpa j'avais
tort ou bien dit il quand même pour être
plus précis j'avais partiellement raison
et pour le reste j'ai globalement tout
inventée de a à z
je n'étais pas le seul mais réponse je
les ai tiré de mes convictions
idéologiques
alors jacques dessin victor est ce que
l'université est devenue sectaire mais
je crois qu'il faut distinguer vraiment
de choses ce qui relève de ce qu'on
appelle la censure dont a été victime
six lits à magasins ce qui en réalité ça
ça a toujours existé depuis mai 68
depuis que au fond un certain gauchisme
universitaire s'est emparé de certaines
universités
n'oubliez pas par exemple je pense 174
quand pasolini était venu à l'université
de vincennes pour présenter un de ses
films badiou et ses amis appelé à
saboter le film fasciste de pasolini
tout simplement parce que pasolini avait
dit des choses qui ne leur convenait pas
donc cet aspect c'est pascal et oui
voilà alors c'est vrai qu'on l'avait un
petit peu dit il avait diminué dans les
années 90 à la suite notamment des
péripéties liées à la chute du mur et il
y avait une peut-être une sorte de
d'amoindrissement de cette forme de
militantisme mais il a toujours un peu
existé ce qui est neuf en revanche c'est
l'apparition de ces travaux bidonné si
l'on peut dire qu'ils remettent en cause
alors là quelque chose de beaucoup plus
grave qui est le coeur même du savoir et
de la production du savoir intellectuel
parce que qu'il y ait des agitateurs
c'est vrai que l'université ç'a toujours
été ce lieu je le répète mais en
revanche là c'est beaucoup plus grave
alors ça me touche pas tous les
départements tout ce qui te pour
concerner ce qu'on appelle les sciences
dures ça reste tout de même très très
très très limité qui compliquait que
beaucoup plus compliqué bon il ya
quelques vraiment qu'à la marge
certains départements dans les sciences
dites molles comme par exemple le droit
ne sont absolument pas généralement
touchées par cela mais ça touche en
revanche c'est vrai certains
départements je pense notamment la
sociologie la science politique et si on
y mène au sens large
et là ça pose en effet de très graves
problèmes parce que ça met en évidence
quoi le ça met en évidence la la la la
victoire dans certains domaines de
production d'un savoir assez disons
fragile la victoire non pas d'un point
de vue scientifique mais d'un point de
vue totalement secteur totalement
idéologique en fait c'est ça cette
dimension et plus on est idéologique
plus on supporte pas le discours
contraire et ça c'est vrai que depuis
quelques années on voit surtout c'est
une importation des travaux
essentiellement anglo-saxons des modes
certaines universités et de certaines
revues parce que ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir le cac qui a été évoqué
n'est pas n'est pas unique il y a eu un
vrai canular à ses célèbres en 2018 ou
des chercheurs ont envoyé des articles
complètement bidon à un certain nombre
de revues classez vous savez qu'on
classe les revues selon leur degré de
soi disant scientificité à des revues
très bien classés qui ont accepté des
articles absolument nous faut que je
vais pas vous dire à tous les titres de
ces articles mais enfin c'était vraiment
délirant et le plus grave c'est pas non
seulement qu'ils a été passé mais c'est
qu'une fois le canular a révélé les
dirigeants de ces revues ont considéré
que ce qui était beaucoup plus grave
c'était que on ait osé leur soumettre un
article de canulars orienté avec des
postures idéologiques visant à les
remettre en cause
donc si vous les gars aucune justement
remise en cause de la part de ses
dirigeants
un certain nombre de ces revues donc ça
c'est très grave parce que ça roulait en
cause l'esprit
de l'université maxime des lieux dans
les think tanks
[Rires]
on a enfin alors je mieux sur les signes
donc sur la façon dont accueillis
comparée à l'université je reviens et je
ferais même distinction vous je me
permettrai dire que puisque moi j'en ai
le souvenir
il ya des universités où effectivement
il ya toujours eu des agitateurs
d'extrême gauche comme d' extrêmement
oui j'ai le souvenir aussi de simone
veil qui pouvaient pas rentrer ni à une
conférence à assas et presse quand
j'étais étudiant j'avais aussi quelques
universités ou les m'était difficile de
pouvoir
être en totale sécurité donc c'est le
jeu c'est on va dire ça fait partie de
ces universités qui sont à déplorer oui
milk dans lequel est là où je suis
d'accord enfin donc ça c'est un premier
point est pour moi il n'y a pas
d'évolution notable
ça a toujours existé il ya un deuxième
sujet que vous évoquez qui est la
question de vous et vous qui dites vous
parler d'idéologie vous me permettrez de
penser qu'il y avait aussi du savoir
quelquefois qui peut être idéologique
moi ce que je trouve
will grâce aux réductions de avec est ce
que je trouve plus grave c'est qu'il n'y
ait pas de critiques et de pensée
critique
c'est ça qu'il faut rechercher une rôle
de l'université et y compris ça permet
quelques fois de démonter ou de trouver
des arguments contre les autres c'est
d'être capacité de pouvoir produire des
pensées critiques c'est par rapport à ce
qu'est à ce qui est fait est donc là où
je ne sais pas si les think tanks y
contribuer
mais c'est possible qu'ils disent aussi
quelques fois un certain nombre de
choses fausses mais je pense que
quelquefois ils le font sans s'en rendre
compte
là en l'occurrence saint-andré
manipulation pardon je reprécise bien
c'est ce que j'appelle une posture
idéologique produire des choses fausses
c'est tout à fait possible hélas
l'erreur est humaine
la posture idéologique c'est de savoir
qu'on produit quelque chose de faux mais
qu'on l'assument tel que l'évoqué
d'ailleurs l'article de ce
d'anthropologues dans le point tel qu'on
l'a su pour des raisons idéologiques
c'est ça donc c'est non seulement la
super leurs recherches
oui mais après d'autres vous diront mais
bon c'est un long débat qu au vous
pouvez aussi quelquefois trouvait pour
des raisons idéologiques
vous pouvez choisir des arguments qui
sont partielles et ça ça peut exister de
la politique dans ces cas là mais je
crois pas que le droit par exemple soit
dénué d idéologie contraire si cette
intolérance
ce refus du débat ça ça doit aussi nous
faire réfléchir sur le rapport de toute
une nouvelle génération internet parce
qu'au fond on regarde on remarque ça
vient beaucoup des états unis à partir
de dar de l'arrivée d'internet de cette
génération qui est née après 1995
aujourd'hui dans beaucoup de campus
américains vous avez des étudiants font
ce qu'ils appellent des safe space c'est
à dire des endroits où à l'entrée on
affiche les idées que l'on peut
développer et celles qui sont interdites
et donc comme ça on estime que du coup
vous êtes en sécurité idéologique à
l'intérieur de ces seuils spaces et ça
c'est directement lié au rapport que
beaucoup de deux jeunes ont avec
internet c'est à dire un lieu où on ne
communique qu'avec des gens qui vous
ressemble qui sont d'accord avec vous et
on développe ce qu'on appelle la
communauté puisque les réseaux sociaux
sont basés sur la communauté et moi je
pense que ça le recul de l'esprit
critique de l'an viii du débat
contradictoire tout je crois qu'il est
aussi liée à cette dérive c'est le fait
de rentrer et jusque vous dites et
j'irai même un peu plein de vous en
disant que d'une part il faut évidemment
retrouver le sens de l'esprit critique
sortir des boules de filtres dans lequel
internet nous plonge et peut-être aussi
trouver un moyen de re consacré de
savoir dire que c'est vrai aujourd'hui
que on en plaisante souvent mais les
gens ont l'impression que google et la
nouvelle encyclopédie oubliant je parle
même pas du contenu mais que que si vous
faites une recherche et que je fais là
même nous n'aurons l'un et l'autre pas
les mêmes résultats
parce que c'est tout ça est classé en
fonction de vos profils de vos
recherches précédentes et c'est donc là
on voit bien que la recherche
d'informations et pas de savoir bailleur
est souvent biaisée et donc dans un
monde où les émetteurs sont multiples et
certainement que c'est dans l'université
il faudrait peut-être réfléchir à la
façon dont on pourrait re consacré ce
qui est le vrai savoir scientifique le
vrai savoir universitaire au delà de
revue qui comme vous l'avez indiqué à
vous entendre ne joue plus tellement ce
rôle parce qu'elle la consécration de
l'information vous avez beaucoup de mal
des réseaux et des plateformes et
effectivement les informations recoupées
vérifier etc
c'est le journaliste n'est ce pas marc
landré oui je me rappelle d'un allemand
qui avait aussi qui a été pris la main
dans le sac il ya quelques années
est-ce que 10 des vignes carrière
extraordinaire il a vu des prix
journalistiques terrible il a reconnu
qu'il avait tout bidonné qui n'est
jamais que les témoignages qui fournira
les reportages de guerre il avait tout
inventé il pèche jamais rencontré
personne donc le bidonnage au figaro
bien sûr mais il peut exister dans le
monde journalistique aussi bon le
bidonnage n'est pas réservé aux
universités mais malgré tout ils
s'attaquent plus facilement aux sciences
molles c'est bien ce que je comprends
oui il devrait surtout pas être dans
l'université à la rigueur il ya une
vieille tradition journalistique depuis
malraux et autres que qui ne devrait pas
être à l'université alors je vous
remercie pour cette belle célébration du
savoir nous nous retrouvons demain point
de vue même heure même punition merci et
très bonne soirée à vous tous
[Musique]